ya sabemos un montón acerca de los
exponentes si nos encontramos por ahí a
un 4 a la 3 ya sabemos que esto es igual
pues tomar el 4 y multiplicarlo 3 veces
o sea 4 por 4 x 4 que bueno hay dos
formas de encontrar este 4 a la 3 una es
ésta y la otra es tomar un 1 y
multiplicar por 4 3 veces pero a final
de cuentas nos queda exactamente lo
mismo que es igual a 4 por 4 16 por 4 64
también sabemos exactamente qué hacer
cuando nos encontramos con exponentes
negativos por ejemplo 4 a la menos 3
nosotros sabemos que este menos que en
el otro vídeo lo colorea vamos de morado
lo que hace este menos es que tomemos el
recíproco ya sea que tomemos 1 entre y
luego esta expresión pero sin el menos
en el exponente o sea 4 a la 3 o que
tomemos el recíproco de este número 4 y
luego eso lo elevemos a la tercera
potencia aunque tengamos uno entre 4 y
eso lo elevemos a la tercera potencia
pero bueno de cualquier forma tomemos el
camino que tomemos para encontrar 4 a la
menos 3 siempre va a ser igual a 1 entre
64 ahora lo que vamos a hacer es algo un
poco más interesante que es tomar
exponentes racionales de exponentes que
son fracciones así es que vamos a pensar
en qué significa 4 elevado a la potencia
un medio así es que ya sabes ponle pausa
por lo menos intenta
adivinar qué significa esto y ya después
de lo pones play y bueno resulta que la
definición matemática en la que bueno en
realidad todo el mundo usa es que 4
elevado a la fracción un medio es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de 4 ok
esa es una definición mundialmente
aceptada y porque lo definimos así pues
porque si lo definimos así tiene un
montón de propiedades muy elegantes y a
la hora de manipular todos los
exponentes y hacer todas las cuentas con
ellos resulta muy conveniente por cierto
a qué nos referimos con raíz cuadrada de
4 nos referimos simplemente a algún
número que si lo multiplicamos por sí
mismo dos veces nos queda lo de adentro
de el radical que es este símbolo de
aquí que en este caso es 4 a ver
seguramente ya sabes cuál es la raíz
cuadrada de 4 a ver cuáles es el número
que si lo multiplicamos por si mismo dos
veces nos queda 4
pues es el número es simplemente 2
porque 2 por 2 que nos denotamos por 2
al cuadrado es igual a 4
entonces la raíz cuadrada de 4 es 2
porque 2 al cuadrado es 4 bueno vamos a
ver otros ejemplos por ejemplo tomemos
por aquí 9 y elevamos lo a la un medio
esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 9
pero la raíz cuadrada de 9 es igual a
haber un número que si lo multiplicamos
por sí mismo dos veces nos de 9
pues eso simplemente es un 3 porque 3
por 3 9 que podemos a escribirlo por
aquí 3 al cuadrado que es igual a 3 por
3 es igual a 9 entonces raíz de 9 es
igual a 3 y la raíz de 9 es igual a 9
elevado a la un medio entonces tú qué
opinas se empieza a notar el patrón no
hacemos más ejemplos bueno de todas
formas vamos a hacer más ejemplos
tomamos por aquí 25 y lo elevamos a la
potencia un medio y entonces esto de
aquí es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 25
así es que estamos buscando un número
que si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo dos
veces nos quede 25 y ese número
obviamente es 5 porque 5 al cuadrado que
es igual a 5 por 5 es igual a 25
si se nota más o menos el patrón no o
sea tenemos aquí 9 a la un medio y 3 al
cuadrado bueno ahora yo quiero que me
digas cuánto crees que vale 8 elevado a
la intención pues lo más natural es
pensar que 8 elevado a la un tercio es
igual a la raíz cúbica de 8 y si
pensaste eso estás completamente en lo
correcto y nosotros ya sabemos cuál es
la raíz cúbica de 8 no porque la raíz
cúbica de 8 es igual a justo es el
número que si lo multiplicamos por si
mismo tres veces nos da igual a 8 y ya
sabemos cuál es el número normal o sea
si tomamos 2 y lo multiplicamos por sí
mismo tres veces lo que obtenemos es 8
entonces la raíz cúbica de 8 es igual a
dos reis y 2 por dos por 2 es igual a 2
a la 3 y otra vez aquí estamos contando
cierto patrón pero bueno sigamos con
esto de los ejemplos ahora tuvimos 64
elevado a la un tercio sabe a cuánto es
igual pues obviamente es la raíz cúbica
de 64 pero la raíz cúbica de 64 es justo
es el número que si lo multiplicamos por
si mismo tres veces nos da 64 y por aquí
acabamos de ver que 4 elevado a la 3 es
igual a 64 entonces 64 a la un tercio es
igual a 4
ahora este asunto se puede generalizar
para cualquier fracción de la forma 1 /
y alguno entero ok podemos tener por
ejemplo 32 elevado a la potencia un
quinto y aquí lo que tenemos que hacer
es pensar en qué número si lo
multiplicamos por sí mismo 5 veces nos
da 32 pero creo que ya sabemos cuál es
ese número no porque tenemos que 32 es
igual a 2 por 2 x 2 por 2 por 2 2 por 2
4 por 2 8 por 2 16 por 232 y qué curioso
aquí tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco
de estos dos que se están multiplicando
entonces 32 elevado a la un quinto es
igual a 2 y bueno la otra forma de
escribir este hecho de la vida real es
poner que 2 elevado a las 5 es igual